en plus des matières habituel les élèves
de 5e année de l'école catherine sumi
arts ont mis sur pied une petite
entreprise lexus et des vieux d'europe
il vient de soi reconnaissance soit
cédée par an qu'ils ont à faire pièce en
tête en pensant côte empiète être
utilisé alors ici on découpe des
morceaux de tissus conduit de cire
d'abeille ans les repas sans une
personne qui va découper une personne
qui veulent le faire
le ping son qui va rassembler les trios
en 3d 30 par 30
on lit pliant prend des vainqueurs 25
plus 6 des 20 m
c'est un remplacement pour des six
plaques
un projet qui va aussi mener les élèves
à parler de leur entreprise et de leur
préoccupation
la fin d'année on va faire un texte
argumentatif donc c'est pour ça qu'on
ait fait un mémoire qui ont aussi baissé
aussi pour sensibiliser les gens qui
encouragent et le vrac et les méprise
ses rennes d'ici 2050 il y aura plus de
plastique dans les océans queue de
poisson
personnellement je crois que c'est la
consigne parce que la consigne beaucoup
de bouteilles qu'on connaissait les
réutiliser ce sont les plus jeunes
citoyens qui seront entendues aux
audiences de la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal
il espère pouvoir changer les choses qui
vont comprendre ainsi que c'est pas
juste une des personnes de plus de 18
ans qui leur parle aussi des enfants
avec leur prochaine génération qui leur
dit aussi qu elles ont besoin de la redd
pour rennes continue à petite échelle
ils vont ils changent le monde dans
l'école des jo en voile les élèves à
dîner avec leurs pilotes s'emballer dans
nos emballages mais à plus grande
échelle ils peuvent avoir aussi un
impact lié en faisant changer les lois
c'est difficile parce qu'on a eu
beaucoup de commandes au mal
leur initiative a beaucoup de succès 500
commandes à livrer on savait pas en
plaindre qu'est-ce que ça allait être
mais - xc certaine là on est un peu
débordé mais c'est pas grave
en face au rpt tellement enthousiaste
deux frères soeurs et jamais pour la
cire d'abeille
le papa de cet élève a aidé à créer le
logo des abeilles en ben ali le nom mais
en faire baisser les abeilles
on travaille tous dans une compagnie
comme les abeilles puis on travaille
tous leurs enfants qui est belle et on
bat les c pour les emballages qu'on fait
ici un nourrissent des passifs radio
canada montréal